c'est la circonscription la plus petite
au pays et c'est là que la nouvelle chef
des verts veut faire sa grande entrée à
la chambre des communes en week end chez
du changement ces scans à mespaul
propose aux électeurs de toronto centre
l'avocate de 48 ans tentera pour la
troisième fois en trois ans de faire
passer ouvert un bastion libéral
en octobre la nouvelle chef avait
surpris en remportant un tiers des voix
lors d'une élection partielle déclenché
en pleine pandémie après la démission du
ministre libéral belle mort nous si nous
avons réussi à gagner une chaire du vote
et de placer deuxième dans trois
semaines aso ces conditions je crois
qu'on a toutes nos chances pour cette
élection
inconnu de la scène politique il y a un
an 1 à mespaul se fait maintenant
reconnaître dans les rues de sa
circonscription mais la course ne sera
pas facile pour autant la chef des verts
tentent de déloger mais aussi yens la
députée libérale sortante et ancienne
animatrice vedette pour maximiser ses
chances 1 à mespaul a choisi de passer
la majorité de la campagne électorale
dans toronto centre je suis à quelqu'un
qui cherche de représenter communauté
pour la première fois je n'ai pas le
luxe d'aller ailleurs et de ne pas à me
connecter avec les gens
pour cette politologue les vins risc
group en mettant tous leurs oeufs dans
le même panier on ne s'attend pas du
coin jeux d'hiver à faire d'autres gains
hormis hormis fait ricaner probablement
de conserver ce qu'ont actuellement en
colombie britannique
et ce n'est pas le seul obstacle qu'elle
est vers ce but des divisions au sein
des troupes écologistes ont récemment
été dévoilé lorsque des membres du parti
ont tenté d'évincer leur nouvelle chef
jacques dworczak
ce militant vert soutient que les
électeurs ne se soucie pas de la crise
interne mais dans ce quartier de toronto
centre ou un as mais paul a fait sa
meilleure performance à la dernière
élection des résidents pensent le
contraire ah non armée port et lui faire
perdre à mes potes matches 1
anna mais pas là demain que les
dernières semaines ont été pénibles mais
s'accroche on doit se laver chaque jour
pour dire je vais me battre aujourd'hui
je veux travailler pour aujourd'hui et
tout ça on considère le 21 septembre
tenir bon jusqu'au jour du scrutin et
espérer que de remporter un siège
suffira pour rallier les troupes ici à
ce midi radio canada toronto